foreign  um  oh  [Music]  foreign  foreign  [Music]  our tank the turret to be exact stopped  working  the others left without warning then the  russian tanks came and we barely managed  to get away  [Music]  [Music]  the leader of the world means  to be the leader of peace  peace  in your country doesn't depend anymore  only on you and your people  it depends on those  next to you  and those who are strong  strong  doesn't mean big  strong  is brave and ready to fight for the life  of his citizens and citizens of the  world  for human rights for freedom for the  right to live instantly and to die when  your time comes  and not when it's wanted by someone else  by your neighbor  slavokray  [Applause]  you